[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael
rosenbom 300th episode
folks Brian how exciting is this my God
how do you feel I can't believe we've
done it
300 Jesus wow guys uh I couldn't have
done this without you guys I really
could not have done it without you guys
I couldn't have done it without Ry I
couldn't done it without Bryce or Jason
that's a fact or your legal team
clearing that song yes you could have
that on there it's fine because on
Instagram you could use it on stories
what was that Johnny Carson theme H
here's Rosie yeah um I just want to say
thank you this has been an absolute
shock that I made it past one episode
let alone
300 I would never have thought this
would be uh a direction in my life that
I would take and and um and having some
success because I feel like uh we have a
devoted fan base we have listeners who
uh find the podcast meaningful and
helpful and and enjoy it and that means
a ton to me and thank you Ryan for being
here thank you for having we've had some
fun yeah you know there's been some
interviews I always I always ask Ryan at
the end I go what do you think yeah and
you know sometimes we're like that was
awesome and sometimes I was like you
know it was okay you know and that's
just part for the course and yeah but
that's rare you know I've almost been
here 5 years at this point no
uhhuh yeah no it can't be this is 2019
summer
yeah we're in 2024 now well I think it's
like four years I mean coming up on it's
like four and a half at this point how
is this possible I don't
know I started in how time fly I guess
cuz Co really hit and it was just like
it was kind of a blur Co screwed a lot
of things up it sure did yeah however
yeah and you know 300th episode is a big
one so I I had to choose a guess that I
thought would fit 300th and it was very
easy to choose it was not easy to
convince them to do
it but I had to pick my uh my buddy my
uh my
Superman Tom Welling for the 300th
episode so uh Tom thank you you for
doing it um I know you thought we' we've
done it so many times that we wouldn't
have anything to talk about but we did
and uh I really appreciated you doing it
and we've become really close friends
over the years which is surprising
because we weren't ever close friends
we're like yeah hey you know I always
like Tom you like me but and we
respected each other but like over the
years we we we have a bond I love his
wife his kids I mean I don't I don't
live here or he doesn't live near me
anymore but we see each other so often
when when we go to cons and we see each
other every week with you doing these so
it's a real treat to have them here um
you guys know the uh if you really
enjoying this podcast all I ask you is
Please Subscribe and help the little
podcast that could and uh at inside of
you podcast on Instagram and Facebook
inside you pod on the Twitter you can
watch us on YouTube please subscribe
write a review keep listening and if you
want to join patreon to support the
podcast that would be Dynamite uh it
really helps patreon ./ inside you I'll
write you a message and um also my
Instagram at the Michel Rosen bomb just
go to my link Tree on the Instagram and
you'll see where what cons Tom and I are
going to Cameo sunspin my band all that
information stores everything you need
is there so I don't need to talk about
it uh even Rosy's puppy fresh breath is
there I talk about that but it's a it's
a product I came out with my buddy Tom
La childhood friend and we like good
breath on dogs
that's all I have to say and it's easy
to use it's like a cap full in their
water based on you know how much water
you have in there it says on the
instructions and it's great and uh
thanks for all the support and um yeah
without further Ado let's get inside of
Tom Tom Thomas
Welling should I do the thing again and
without further
Ado let's get inside of
Thomas
Welling it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you with Michael
Rosen
[Music]
bomb inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience well well well if it
isn't Thomas Welling I never get to see
you long time no see thanks for having
me yeah thanks for coming this is I know
you were reluctant it's the uh
300th episode starring I I just wanted I
don't care if we talk about nothing for
the next 45 minutes I wanted you to be
my 300th guest uh you're one of my
favorite people on the planet and uh
it's always easy talking to you and by
the way have you started losing your
hair yet I know you're you're easing up
on 50 soon no I got hair people ask me
at the
cons I got hair I got lots of hair I
just don't want to
like do it and my mom has hair so I'm
good that's what I hear wait wait wait
did you say your mom has hair she does
well most moms have hair Ryan does your
mom have hair M okay I mean that's not
something you say well my mom still has
her hair she really your dad it's a high
school thing it's
G you have to look into like your mom's
dad who may or may not have hair it's
it's far as I know and my mom's dad did
have hair and my mom has hair so I think
I'm good all right good for you and
you're 40 6 I think so let me ask you
they always ask you that question do you
feel
46 no where's your mind I feel 20 I feel
like 26 and 82 at the same time yeah
because I this is a guy I don't know
what that adds up to we should do that
math because I just thought about that
right now well last weekend you were uh
you threw your back out and it was hard
to watch you were uh wearing a brace you
were like you were like me usually with
my back
well the the difference is if I if I may
you you're in constant pain and you've
had surgery and you're about to go in
another surgery for me it's just it
feels like once a year my back just goes
take a break you know and some people
say that's from a mental standpoint I
don't see that maybe I need to talk to a
therapist about that you do but um my
back was out I wasn't in pain my back
just didn't work so I was
moving like one fifth of how I used to
work were moving slow I didn't want to
say anything but we did a uh we did a
con a few weeks back before the holidays
and uh we went to Nashville which was a
great time but I guess it happened to
you on the planes so we did Smallville
nights which is an intimate evening with
us that we do at the cons which we'll do
one in Albuquerque if you want to go to
the cons look on my link tree we're
we're interacting with the fans and
we're reading scenes from the show and
it's like this intimate thing and you
look like 90 years old just because
you're back I borrowed a cane from a fan
yeah he borrowed a cane from the
audience he borrowed a cane this is like
old Lex old
Clark talking about our uh you know it's
funny to you know as much as your pain
of as I've had in like surgeries and
stuff I don't like I still feel in my
head I feel young but like we you're
sharp yeah you're sharp well I don't
know how sharp I am but like we went to
a rooftop bar at the hotel and I went
with the guys like uh you know some
friends of mine and we were all up there
even Erica came up there Erica Durant
and I took a laugh I wasn't there right
you weren't there you were in your bed
you know on Advil back in pain yeah but
I uh I walked I took a lap I wanted to
check out the place scope
it and I felt like I was everyone in
there's father just by looking at them
not how I felt but when I looked at them
I was like oh my gosh you're like 20
years old I it's funny you spark it you
spark a memory for me just in this
moment
um when I
was I think 1920 I was living in New
York as a quote unquote model and we
were getting complete access to every
nightclub with nothing to pay for
nothing else and it was just a bunch of
models
everywhere and then Smallville kind of
hit I remember we we went to promote the
first season of Smallville and I some of
of the places were still around and I
went to this one place I won't mention
it but I went back there and
now they let me in because now I'm on
this TV show and I got back to this room
that I remember where all these people
were and everybody looked so much
younger than I was even at like 22 I was
like oh wow yeah yeah what are you gonna
do I mean let me ask you you said you
know you talk about you know when you
first got Smallville and
um I know you did construction before
you were
modeling if first of all do you still
honestly because a lot of people and
bartending do and bartending do you
still love acting honestly yeah you do I
have a friend of mine right now um
currently I don't know when this is
going to air and I just he just helped
finish a movie that didn't work so they
brought down this new producer and he
was a guy who when when we did these
last four days of this movie that was
that was shot in Italy I have two movies
coming coming out in the new year I
don't even I think they've changed the
names of the titles but we shot in Italy
um we couldn't finish it so we shot it
in uh Dallas and I met this producer and
he was him and I become friends because
he was on set with us if you know what I
mean he was like moving things and like
doing things and we had a we had a fight
sequence that I was able to help out
with and then he moved it we just became
like buddies and he called me recently
and he was like Hey you know I got this
movie I want you to and you're like oh
yeah sure you do but he's like but I'm
doing this other movie and we need a
sheriff do you want to do it for no
money and I was like I be honest with
you I go yes like because of the
relationship with him and I go yes and
I'm gonna play hopefully I'm gonna play
the sheriff for probably one day two
days really why cuz you because you love
it I read this script and I love the
script and I love this guy and you and I
have spoke spoke about this before is as
you have the opportunity you want to
work with people you like yes you know
this guy says Hey C I need you I me like
if you were like I need you by the way
that's what we're doing right now you're
like I need you for this I want you to
do this podcast and that because you
know I have other things to do but I'm
here with you because you asked me and
that's a beautiful situation but what
would you do if you were still living in
Michigan and you didn't have the looks
to get you to the modeling and the and
then the modeling to the acting and all
this stuff and let's say it just stopped
at bartending and construction what do
you honestly think if you could honestly
say hey this is probably what I would
have done my grandfather was a
firefighter and I've always thought
about that because what I love about
firefighters is they help people yeah
you know maybe that turned into the
Clark thing I don't know like when the
cops show up you're like ah [__] but
when the firefighters show up they're
they're there to help you I mean that's
a maybe nonset I got rise attention
there but I maybe I would have gone
there I have friends who've gotten into
firefighting in and out of it you would
have gone in a firefighting to help
people but instead you became an actor
playing a character that helps and
pretending to help but you have helped
many people out there who this show was
everything that they they needed at at
that time you know when 911 happened
people how many people have told us how
important the show was to them or when
when they saw it with their dad and and
their dad's no longer with them but it
was a memory it was like or they got
them through a tough time well I mean I
I agree with that um you and I spend a
lot of time with the cons and we meet
people who've watches shows with growing
up with their like parents who maybe are
not here anymore but it's still inspires
them but I will throw this back in your
face and say that I have seen you
physically help more
people than I don't you know you have
taken effort to help people around
McDonald House and whatnot you have
actually become a superhero in your own
life and I'm I'm not trying to like well
no I appreciate it but I you know I
always feel like and it's true I I don't
do enough I think I could do a lot more
and I think I'm more fulfilled and I we
all can I feel like I have more purpose
when I do help people because I feel
like I feel like I feel like but I think
that
true I don't know altruism true like
purpose is being selfless and uh you're
going to get purposed by doing something
for someone else that you because you
want to do that because you want to help
them and you want to help them get
through a dark time or and so I don't
think that I do enough I think a lot of
people could say that but I honestly
think I should do a lot more and you
know uh but thank you well I also if if
if I may interject I think one of the
things that I get from listening to this
podcast because I am a listener um I
know that and I think I'm still a
patriot I signed up at one point I think
I am I'll have to look you do a good job
of and you inspire me to this you take
care of yourself so you can help other
people like I see you making efforts and
I you know whether it's the interesting
um interviews you have with Zack Levi
which he always he always has a lot to
say but I love listening to it yeah you
what I like is you say you got to take
care of yourself so you can take care of
other people and I think that's a very
wonderful thing and Ryan I don't mean to
put you on the point but I just looked
up and saw you here but I don't know if
you get that from this or not and I'd
love your feedback but like Michael
inspires me and I wonder if that's
really nice not to put you in the point
you can say no I don't Inspire Ryan at
all I don't Inspire him no but I agree
with what you're saying a lot like
that's and that's something that I
learned a lot in therapy is like you and
because I do a lot of helping other
people but it helps a lot if you can
help yourself first so that you can put
yourself in a position to be helpful for
other people well not I was a I grew I
grew up I I'm an eagle scout like I went
through the Boy Scout oh wow I didn't
know that
nerd news alert it's going to Trend nerd
alert
um inside of you is brought to you by
Shopify um I love Shopify I I mean it is
unbelievable if you I never thought I
would have a store um online and I
thought it just sounds complicated and
probably difficult to use
Shopify is the easiest thing I've ever
experienced it's like you put your
product up on the you know like for
instance a new t-shirt well you put you
press products it says new product sure
new product I put a description of what
the product is I put a picture of the
product I just upload it which is easy I
put the price uh the weight I have a
little scale and I'm done and then boom
it's on my website and let the money
roll in it's that easy Shopify makes
your life so easy I don't know how
everybody isn't on this Shopify is the
global Commerce platform that helps you
sell at every stage of your business
from the launch your online shop stage
to the real life store stage all the way
to the did we just hit a million orders
stage Shopify is there to help you grow
whether you're selling scented soap or
offering outdoor outfits Shopify helps
you sell everywhere from their
all-in-one e-commerce platform to their
in-person POS system wherever and
whatever you're selling Shopify has got
you covered Shopify helps you turn
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout up to 36%
better compared to other leading
Commerce platforms and sell more with
less effort thanks to to Shopify magic
your AI powered Allstar Shopify Powers
10% of all e-commerce in the US and
Shopify the global force behind all
birds rothis and Brook linen and
millions of other entrepreneurs of every
size across 175 countries plus shopify's
extensive help resources are there to
support your success every step of the
way because businesses that grow grow
with Shopify sign up for a $1 per trial
period at shopify.com
inside all lowercase go to shopify.com
inside now to grow your business no
matter what stage you're in shopify.com
inside this show is sponsored by
betterhelp guys you don't need me to sit
here and talk to you about this but I'm
going to um you know how important
therapy is this podcast talks about
mental health and well-being and and all
that other stuff and it's it's so
important important to me in my
lifestyle now that it's helped me
substantially I know it's helped
millions of other people and better help
is a huge part of that um it's
affordable therapy online where you can
change your therapist like that if you
don't like them or don't feel like
they're the right fit um it's it's so
easy to use you fill out a questionnaire
that takes barely any time and you're
ready to go and it's the new year so if
you've got things we've got things we
need to talk about um better help is is
there Ryan around new years's right we
get obsessed on how to change ourselves
instead of just expanding on what we're
already doing right I I do it I write a
New Year's resolution I write all these
things and you know maybe you finally
organized one part of your space and you
want to tackle another or maybe you're
you're taking your supplements every
morning right now you want to actually
eat breakfast too whatever your goals
are for the new year therapy helps you
find your strengths so you can ditch the
extreme resolutions and make changes
that really stick I'm telling you when I
stick to therapy it's better it's life
is better and what happens is I used to
do this where I'm feeling good now I
don't need therapy it's like not
changing your oil every couple months or
it's like not these are
Necessities that if you stop doing
something it's going to you know what I
mean I think it's just really important
look if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule even if you've added some new
routines in there just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge why
wait for a new year when you can
celebrate you and the changes you've
already made right now therapy from
better help can get you there and help
you love you love the journey love this
new year celebrate the progress you've
already made visit better he ./ insid
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
inside I didn't understand it as I was
going through it but one of the merit
badges you get his lifeguarded and now
that we're talking about this and this
is all just sparking because you and I
did not prepare anything about this
interview no except one thing which I'm
going to ask you later but it's not
about us fine but um lifeguarding Merit
when they teach you like you already
know how to swim and they teach you how
to like save people the number one thing
is if you don't think you can save the
other person you save yourself because
that other person will bring you
down and I think what I'm trying to do
is kind of spin this to your podcast
which is get yourself in a place of
status or status however you want to say
it or
homeostasis so that you can then help
other people it is it is is in layman's
terms the analogy I would I think you're
you're aiming for is when you're in a
plane they always say put your mask on
before you put the other one mask on so
you could help help yourself so you
could help uh you know other people like
a kid or whatever but anyway listen on
that note I know you you don't get too
private and we don't have to get private
because I I love your wife Jess and I
think she's just unbelievable so I know
she likes you more than I'm comfortable
with honest come on she's like he's so
he's so magnetizing and I was like what
magnetizing I've never had a woman call
me magnetizing magnetic well I think
it's an episode of smava that wasn't it
made me uncomfortable as well oh great
now he's going to hate me for something
I didn't do uh what has Jessica taught
you about yourself that you're working
on to be a better maybe a better person
or what what is it that you've gone oh
my God she's right CU we've had
conversations where you're like you said
something and you're like I'm like well
you're like you're like well she's right
what do you want me to do about it how
much time do you guys have but listen
hopefully when you're married and you
meet the right person they make you a
better
person no it's and it's challenging I
mean listen it's does she tell you to be
patient yeah but you here's the thing
like okay I'm gonna come back to your
other question but this question
patience you can't tell someone to be
patient like there's a whole unwrapping
of why someone's on a because people
you're telling to be patient don't
understand what you're talking about
however what Jessica has not told me but
it's helped me reflect upon how I
operate and I think that's even more
important like I might wake up a little
earlier in the morning and when she
wakes up I'm sort of like you know hey
this this this this and she's
like time out you know what I mean and
so she's taught me how to be more
respectful of her space how to
understand my own operating system just
like hey in the moment maybe think
about how you want to operate instead of
just
like you know throwing up
on so almost take a beat to go hey how
do I want toct yourself collect yourself
I I don't do that enough I don't collect
myself enough no you're impulsive but
you're you're you're no but you are but
this is why do this and that's why we
have a good relationship you're
impulsive but it always comes from such
a beautiful place that everyone allows
it to happen Okay sometimes I feel I
mean that is a good way everyone loves
you because you're it's all heart and I
I guess so sometimes I get annoyed with
myself like why can't you be more
patient why can't you be quieter why
can't you be less impulsive dude I'm I'm
no one bugs me more than I do I know and
but I've gotten better in in our
relationship of trying not to bug my
wife more with with my my impulses right
do you uh uh do you think I hope we have
to interview her next well I yeah I
would do that I I just I've noticed in
you a huge change now I don't want to
say no it is it's for the better now I
don't know if it's Jess I don't know if
it's um just your experience doing these
cons and just a new outlook after
Smallville because you were so in that
world for so many years and so like the
go-to guy we need you for this we need
you for that we need you and you're a
very private person and you went through
a divorce and all these things and I and
maybe finding your soulmate but I I feel
like there's just a calmness about you
that I'm more comfortable being around
like I wasn't always comfortable being
around you because I felt like ah you
don't want to be there you're a little
tense you're short like you don't have a
lot of patience that was there that was
the whole Smallville was that yeah and I
feel like now you go to these coms
and you're not always let's go let's go
hurry's you're kind of just like you're
just you're the calm one you're like
you're just chill you're in the room
you're talking to people you're talking
to fans you're you're engaging you're
like a I don't want to say a different
person because you weren't it wasn't a
person I didn't like but you are a
different person yeah I I mean I would
like to hope so I I still have some
things but I know what you mean and
because a couple cons ago you actually
said something about it and it was at
the same time where I had happened upon
a conscious
of what makes you happy and I don't what
is Happy what makes you happy well when
you get what you want it's happy when
you don't get you want you're not happy
but what do you really want and when you
don't get you what you want can't you
just be happy within yourself and with
what you have and what are and and what
I put on top of that from the con
experience that you talking about is
what are you really in control of and
what what's really going to go wrong
like you can be be yourself right you
know give and be calm and that's maybe
what you've seen in me um I'm still
working on it as we all do yeah and but
um yeah I I mean literally we've talked
about this before but on Smallville it
was all just I felt like I was like a
boxer who was just like this all the
time yeah you're always just defending
yourself and just trying to yeah yeah
and now you're trying to survive well
let me ask you this we went to Nashville
and we did this
and there was hug tornado and you know
horribly and sadly people lost their
lives well when this thing's coming at
us and the sky is just this color I've
never seen and the alarms are going off
and it's the the warnings are coming up
on your on your alerts on your what do
they call those iPhone alerts Amber
Alerts or Whatever It Is Well Amber is
missing children Oh missing children
it's not that one it's just an alert
yeah any but you're in a room and
everyone's phone goes off right so what
I'm saying is is they made us all go
down the entire con hotel to the were
you there for what I said to the parking
structure and like it was serious like
Jens and Ackles and me and Tom and Jared
we all went down to the parking
structure with all these fans with all
these people in the hotel and we were
awaiting what instructions on what to do
next and the first thing I was thinking
of now well I actually I'm thinking of
now is you know I'm kind of carefree and
I'm like I'm not worried I'm just like
well I just have to take care of myself
but at were you at all thinking were you
worried were you thinking oh you know
I've got these two boys and my wife at
home um did that that occur to you at
all do you ever think of that stuff like
it's so funny because I I literally got
a slap in the face from Kim who works
with us physical or mental no no no it
was it was mental but like I come I come
back to the room you know we're we're
both about to be done for the day which
everybody loves to be done for the day
and uh we get back there the alert goes
off off and Kim was like kind of and she
runs the show she's awesome for these
and uh and it was like okay we all have
to go down to the parking garage third
level uh there's a tornado coming we all
need to go and I turned her and I go
well I don't need to go and she goes
what do you mean I'm like I mean and I
literally said to her such a this is so
stupid I go I'm an adult I could do
whatever I want CU I was thinking I'm
going to walk back two blocks of the
hotel right and she looks at me and she
goes do you really want your wife to
hear that you're the one person that
leaves and
dies and leaves your wife and two kids
and I was like let's go down to the
parking garage so it's like no one's per
you know like because I was just like I
want to go I want to go and you know me
one of the things that works for me at
work and this is a sidebar everything
that's wrong with me works on set like
me on set all my everything crazy and
like neotic
it all works in life is is it's more of
an adaptation if that makes any sense so
when she's like we of to go downstairs
we have to go and I'm like well I don't
have to go and then when she said it to
me I was like and I told my wife this
story puts things into perspective hey
to the do the boys ever bring you to
tears is there any something is there
something that you're you know kids
where they do things and it just makes
you like in a good way like a like
emotional way like these are my boys
them more than anything it's distracting
how instantaneous they they absorb your
emotion in the in the best way like I
went for a walk with my two boys
yesterday and we went up in the hills
and we were it's all beautiful and they
just start doing things and saying
things and they say things that you
don't know where they got from like
sometimes they say things and you're
like oh they heard that from me they
heard that from their mom they heard
that from that show we watched and then
them coming out with things that like
you don't know where they come from and
but with such beaut
I mean it's disorienting in a beautiful
way yeah that's that's how I would say
it I love that um it's great do you
think do you is there a pressure on you
uh I know you had a good childhood like
your your parents were were good parents
right were
um do you feel like there's a pressure
like to be a good father to always do
the right things are you hard on
yourself are you are you just embracing
this whole world of fatherhood okay like
it's it's tough but then you see the
beauty in them like I referred to my
other story but going on the hike with
them it's like you see these beautiful
people making choices on their own and
they're only four and six two years old
it's about two
two yeah but it's it's the most
important thing in my life and it it's
it's like a the tent pole in my life for
right now of course yeah I mean listen I
know this is maybe a dumb question but
I've thought of this question like um if
somebody said hey it's all
over this is uh this is what you've
done like you take that any way you want
would you be proud of what you've
accomplished um is it good enough for
you cool uh no it's
not no and I but I mean that's like I'm
not I mean I'm proud of it but not
enough like I feel like there's more and
I think the main part is is raising my
my my
boys um kind of like what you said I
feel like there's there's more to
give am I proud of what we accomplished
like with us on our show yeah I think it
stands up in our podcast that we do
together I'm like this is legit like if
my kids watch that show that's great but
that's a TV show um my my thing that I
think about is how can I be an example
for my children and as is much more
important yeah but I I look at you and
I'm like star of a TV show made a ton of
money made a lot of people happy
beautiful sweet wife um two beautiful
kids live in a really cool place like if
it all ended you know uh if God forbid
I'd say dwelling had a great
life well now would be now would be a
good time because both my boys like you
know Thompson's
favorite although they play with all the
different characters when I when I ask
Thompson who's his favorite superhero he
looks at me and he says quietly Superman
but then he goes and plays with Iron Man
and like he because he's he's already
seen that he's already seen our show um
I don't think Rocky's familiar with it
yet but when you have young children at
this at this age they still think I'm
awesome um they haven't figured it out
yet you know what I mean they haven't
figured out that you're you're not
awesome no they know it they know it
dad's always their favorite person you
know I always think this of you are you
a messy person I have a feeling you're a
messy person and just [__] at you
constantly you know that's an easy
question to answer I'm messy but I'm
clean how do what does that mean you
take a shower and then you take a [__]
on the floor I have clean clothes that
aren't organized yeah I'm I'm not dirty
but I'm messy like I I take a shower
before I go to bed I like to be clean
but I'm not exactly organized I have a
feeling Ryan's
messy I I i' kind of that way the messy
clean no I all my clothes are clean yeah
they're just not organized no my they're
organized I mean uh I would like I just
look at like my my desk is like a little
bit chaotic but I know where everything
goes I just have I have stacks of hard
drives yeah uh yeah like
I'm I'm I'm more functional than I am oh
this needs to be like let me move let me
move this right here let me tell you
something let me tell you something my
old therapist who was right about this
one
thing said you have to have everything
around you organized and put together or
you will fall apart that's your
personality everything has to be neat
everything has to be organized so
because your mind's so
disorganized that it helps me so if my
everything's solid everything's if I
think that I have to do this this room's
a mess this then I'm not focusing I have
this add so I have to make sure
everything around me is good and then I
could sit there and I could write and I
could focus like when I leave this room
I like it a certain way Ryan knows I
like the pillows to be nice I like this
podcast room to be like when I walk in
the next time it's great looks great
ready to go who wouldn't right but I
will say that our time on set you and I
share this you walk on a set and it's
not a it's not a proclamation but it's
what's going
on what's what's what's the structure
that I can be creative within and as
long as that's all taken care of I can
be creative if not I'm distracted and I
can't be creative yeah that's kind of
the the the other side of that but I
agree with what he's saying I don't I
don't need everything to be perfect to
be
I know I think that's a personal I think
that's certainly a
personality inside of you is brought to
you by rocket money now if you've heard
rocket money on this podcast before
you're probably going oh well they must
be doing well with rocket money well the
reason is it's something that helps
everybody universally and is easy to use
and everybody should be doing this
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills I mean how
many times Ryan we talked about this
where we like you should watch the show
I'm like well I don't have
fluto well I guess I'll have to spend
$15 and then watch it and then forget
that I'm subscribed to it and then all
of a sudden I'm $100 down at the end of
the year because I didn't cancel fluto
or you get roped in with a three-month
free trial yeah money's just flying out
your account man and you have no idea
where it's going well I know Ryan it's
it's all those
subscriptions between streaming services
fitness apps delivery services parenting
apps it's endless we're all guilty of
this but we shouldn't be losing money we
need rocket money Michael they'll even
try to get you a refund for the last
couple months of wasted money and
negotiate to lower your bills for you by
up to 20% seriously seriously all you
have to do is take a picture of your
bill and Rocket money takes care of the
rest wow and Rocket money has over 5
million users and has helped saved its
members an average of $720 a year with
over 500 million in cancelled
subscriptions stop wasting money on
things you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions by going to
Rocket
money.com inside that's rocket
money.com inside
rocket.com inside inside you is brought
to you by wry being a king or queen
might seem enticing but more often than
not it comes at the expense of
everything else like your freedom your
privacy and sometimes even your head the
creators of Wes even the rich are
bringing you a brand new podcast called
even the Royals where hosts Brooke and
Arisha pull back the curtain on royal
families past and present from all over
the world to show you the darker side of
what it means to be royalty from stories
about one of the most infamous Royals in
history Mary Antoinette but everything
you know about her is wrong after she
became Queen at just 19 years old she
ended up in a battle with the French
press that started a series of
impossible to believe events it's
History's Greatest smear campaign and it
had deadly consequences or what might be
the worst Royal marriage of all time
between King George ivth and Carolyn of
Brunswick it's a story involving
catfishing fake pregnancies and It All
Leads to a divorce trial where the whole
world sat on the edge of their seats to
see how it would all play out follow
even the Royals on the wondery app or
wherever you get your podcasts you can
binge even the Royals ad free right now
on wonder
plus do you are you honestly proud of
yourself can you can you step back and
look up from the outside in and say dude
good job good job or are you really hard
on yourself like you don't see all the
success you just kind of you don't take
you're not you're not aware of all the
things you've actually
done it's funny this would be a good
question for my wife um no and I I don't
I mean that in the best way because she
said to me she's like I'm very proud of
the work we did and now then our in our
re rewatch podcast I'm able to enjoy it
at the time I didn't because I didn't
know what it was um I'm proud of it I I
I I think my kids will be proud of it
when they see it as well I I just think
there's more out there for me to express
if that answers the question but yeah at
one point she kind of said like it's not
how I find myself like I don't walk
around being like I'm the guy from that
show I really don't and I I think she
respects that I think she does um but uh
yeah I don't like that's something we
did and that's great and we I'm more
proud of it now than I was when we did
it sure but there's more to come that's
that's sort of how I feel well there's
also like the the good guy aspect of it
like I was watching this video and it
somebody on YouTube did uh nice guys and
mean guys and they had like Mike Myers
is a is a terror on set and people all
these things but then they had Adam
Sandler he walks into like a restaurant
and the woman's like oh sorry she says
we don't have any whatever and he goes
oh all right or he says we don't have
any seats for you sorry you know we
can't and he's like oh okay problem and
he's like all right all right and he
left with his daughter and he didn't he
wasn't like you know listen I'm an actor
I'm on a show uh can you hook me up um
yeah uh I I just I think would would you
look we've all been um we we we've all
said things done things had our actions
didn't always uh make us proud if we
look back I mean just as a human being
not as I can't anything specific I'm not
really referring to but is there
something about like any of any do you
look back at your actions albeit on set
or in personal life and go you know what
I was immature and stupid and I I really
wish I wouldn't acted that way and I I
wish I could apologize to that person
now yeah and I and I think especially
with with this podcast being toward like
mental health in the best way of
self-reflection being able to learn from
those things like there there was a time
they were directing an episode of
Smallville outside in the parking lot
and I was trying to finish an episode I
was directing and starring in in the
basement of the Production Studio and we
were trying to do this 300 sort of thing
like a like a slow bullet going and
Clark does this and
outside they kept calling on the radio
that they had problems with problems and
I it was like three or four we had to
stop when they were rolling and back and
forth and I lost I lost my [__]
composure and I went out there and I
raised my voice toward
a crew who I know I know all their
names and the first D comes over and
says Tom Tom Tom I need you to and I'm
like I'm not g to calm down it was just
this so such an immature situation right
and he goes and he I don't remember what
he said but he said something that shut
me up like he probably said shut the
[__] up and he pointed up in the sky and
there was a a like a crane with a light
with a 5k or two up there MH and it was
moving like 10t he's like we're trying
to get that guy down and I'm telling you
dude I've never felt this since or
before this
complete H like I am so out of line
right now embarrassed or unin and
uninformed and embarrassed and
everyone's like that's okay you didn't
know you didn't have the information and
this and that that experience has helped
me now as I deal with SE situations of
life situations going on where you
remind yourself hopefully that you may
be triggered but maybe the next trigger
is to remind yourself you might not have
all the information for the situation it
might not be about you it's about
something
else even better yeah yeah and then I
never did it again by the way I never
raised my voice upet ever again yeah
when you when you watch that video of
Christian Bale and he's just losing his
[__] and going nuts do you are are you
were you shocked could you ever did you
you ever think you could do something
like that I'm glad you brought that up
because that's what I did it's a that's
a that's what I did in the story just
still before I think you and I talked
about this and it was like oh that's so
everybody was like it's a horribly he
did that I'm like they call it
stacking in in Psychology it's a it's a
stacking of this emotion that adds to
the explosion you're stacking up the
dynamite and then it explodes right I'm
I don't know Christian Bale I don't
knowbody there there's been some behind
the scenes things which help me believe
what I what I'd like to think which is
he's been dealing with this he's asked
for changes it hasn't been changed I
don't agree with how he dealt with it
but when it happened I was like well
there's other actors I mean there's wae
Phoenix had a very famous
intimate why they leak this information
is
actually kind of horrible to me I think
it I think it's a good thing because if
you leak that sort of information I mean
look there should be privacy and no one
should have that but like somebody was
like you know the guy who grabs the the
tape or the film and takes and gets a
transferred he's like you know what I'm
going to take a copy of this and no
one's going to know it was me and I'm
going to air it because this guy's a
[__] [__] now I think he's a
brilliant actor Christian Bale I I don't
know the details but I bet it helped him
I bet he'll never do that again I bet I
agree if if something is presented to
you where you see yourself in another
light and you don't like it that's when
you make a change when you hit rock
bottom is the only time that you realize
your uh you know your issues your um
what's the word your uh your freaking um
personality your the way you handle
things affects other people and there's
consequences I think when you see that
you you that's the best chance you have
to make changes I I have a friend of
mine who and I I'm not gonna say his
name because he's too F he's literally
too famous to mention and years 30 years
ago he did a film with a very famous
director and I'm sorry to be that guy
who's not naming names but here's the
situation his director called him in and
said I need you to watch dailies and he
walked in and he's watching the daili
and he's seeing himself on camera
literally chewing his own mouth
off because he'd been doing cocaine oh
wow and the director was like I want you
to see this
and the story was told to me as a as a
as a coming to Jesus moment for him and
he goes That's when I stopped doing
cocaine so it speaks to what you said
when he saw
himself he was like I I can't be that
person anymore we
justify what we we feeling in any given
moment but when you're being
photographed and mean that's why when
like you're doing something is when go
let me video it you're like whoa who you
know like there is a thing about that
but if we
were maybe that'd be helpful I don't
know I'm I did something where I was on
a recording of something and I thought
the recording was over and I started
talking to my friend and saying [__] and
just joking between two friends who if
people heard some of the [__] we say
they'd be like Monsters because we're
just like it it's not real it's like
complete exaggeration but like you'd be
like first of all it would hurt feelings
and it would and I but no one heard it
but somebody texts me and goes hey
you're still on on air yeah and I go
what and if people would have heard it
it would have
I'm telling you the feeling I had was
absolute shame and embarrassment even
though no one heard it and it wasn't
that bad but I felt like I'm I'm done I
mean it was it was horrible but thank
God you know got be care friends I have
friends who have lost their jobs talking
to people who have actually become
presidents for seeing worse things you
know what I mean like it's something are
said like you and I even Bryce and Ryan
like when we're off air we have
conversations it's not horrible but it's
not worth sharing it's between friends
right and that's okay because it's we
all understand the context of the humor
and what we're
saying I hear you it's a scary thing if
someone were to just listen to what you
were saying without you knowing they
were listening yeah hey let me ask you
if uh Allan miles came to me and you and
said listen yes we've got a Smallville
movie I already answered it well
Smallville movie I mean I'd be like yes
let's hear it I don't know how it would
happen came an idea for a Smallville
movie or five years later or it was
right before like let's say they just
said we have this idea it's before you
still be before you come Superman and
it's this little window here it's this
like and we make a movie and we've got
this great idea and it's going to be on
Netflix would you consider it of course
I mean listen I I was thinking about
this the other day right before we did
our our our talk F podcast but like no
we were on one of the most successful
shows in the history of Television like
top 50 from that show I've never got an
incoming call from anyone involved in
that show for further work and I don't
mean to I'm not saying that like I don't
feel bad about that I don't harp on
anybody about that but you would think
that when you're success successful you
would be continued successful with
successful people but I think the time
has changed
it is sort
of sad I think in this world there are a
few people who they come up together
they start making things and they put
all their friends in it and they they
constantly use their friends there's
very few people like that um I've had
many friends who have become tremendous
successes some put their friends in the
movies some don't they're also under
different influences sure Studio casting
let's give them that sure but it's
people
think it's hard hard enough getting a
movie from people that don't know you
but when you're not getting things from
people that do know you then it's like
oh my god well now I'm really [__]
that's true it's it's funny but uh but
it's cool that you would do a Smallville
movie I think that it'd be it' be
hilarious the concept they'd be like Tom
I want you to get ripped I want you to
lose 20 pounds Rosen bomb I want you to
do this I want you to look this you're
shaving your and we're we're doing this
and we're getting you know and we're get
and it'd be pretty fun I don't know if
is that more that sounds more like Al
Than Miles by the way yeah miles be like
no no no terrible idea terrible idea you
have addictions I do buying clothes bags
sweatshirts every time I see you've got
a new [__] bag and I'm like where'd
you get that you've got a new uh
cordless uh speaker one of those
Bluetooth speakers you're you're the
gadget guy to just tell you always like
stop buying [__] I'm I I it's funny you
say this
I'm I'm I'm always trying to find like
the right like the right headphones the
right clothes like simplifying my travel
but in trying to simplify it I buy more
things which is so so ridiculous like
headphones or we travel so much it's not
like we're going out buying Porsches or
Lamborghinis we're buying I buy
T-shirts my friend Jess is always like
do you need another t-shirt I'm like yes
I do I need t-shirts and sneakers that's
it I don't need much you do because I
see the same five or six from you all
the time I know why do I no but I always
wear the same t-shirts cuz I don't know
anyway listen can we talk about Tom I
know you had an incident a long time ago
a lot of people don't know about where
you sort of and you're everything's
great now and you're fine God willing
yeah um but you had an incident and and
it was where tell me about that well was
a little Health scare um which I didn't
necessarily experience in that without
context I'm sorry mentioned it but
everybody around me did and I mean
Jessica kind of literally saved my life
and when I was in the hospital obviously
my parents flew in you know we talked
about how my parents are awesome and
there were really only two other people
that came to visit me in the hospital
one was with budy Ryan and it's funny
because I don't remember seeing him
there because I was still sort of in the
hospital mode yeah the only person I
remember actually visiting me was you
which you didn't need to be there didn't
have to come there I I don't even know
how you knew about what was happening um
and then throughout that and me sort of
kind of coming back from whatever it was
you were there to to be like hey buddy
let's go hang out like let's go up to
the you know the Mahal tennis club like
let's get out of the house that's when
we started hanging out really after that
incident and you really you know and it
helped me because you allowed me to kind
of talk about some of the frustrations I
was having um um so thank you you're
welcome um maybe I've never said that
before but yeah that was it was a it was
a it was a weird experience it's sort of
like is it like you have tent polls in
your life you know you know you were
born you graduated high school or I
didn't go to college but maybe you have
a 10 year long television show in that s
yeah that's College Smallville college
and then you have children and then you
have health things and it it was a tent
pole and and I do know that
what you did for me was very helpful so
thank you uh and continue to do and we
don't have to of course man of course
but and we don't have to get into it but
it was a scar because you like passed
out right in a DMV yeah you passed out
completely unconscious pretty much and
and in front of everybody it was like
were you just standing there do you
remember anything you said before you
just passed out well one of the things
about what happens is you you don't
remember because that's how your brain
protects yourself but if I my my wife
Jessica was standing to my right if I
had fallen to my left there would have
been more serious consequences but I
kind of I felt to my right and she kind
of like helped me to the
ground um and then it was I I woke up at
the hospital so and then it was just
trying to figure things out and we did
and everything's fine now but um it was
weird I mean I think Jessica had to deal
with it more than I did if that makes
any sense because I was not conscious
yeah I remember it was just it's one of
those things and she was and by the way
Jessica was pregnant at the time what
tomon and what's scary is it just it
happened there was no Rhyme or Reason
you had no health issues if it happened
10 minutes ahead of time I'd have been
on the highway driving 65 miles an hour
and that wouldn't have been good
no inside of you is brought to you by
discover if you like like using debit
over credit don't you think it's time
you also get rewarded well now you can
with discover cashback debit it's a
checking account that rewards everyone
with cash back on everyday purchases
plus there are no fees period we're
talking date nights thrifting the latest
trends nights out with your friends and
it's now earning you cash back with
discover cashback debit check out
eligibility and terms at discover.com
slash back debit Discover Bank member
FDIC brenon Fraser working with him and
I know you did this you know it aired on
Warner Brothers and it was this stuff
you did in South South Africa and was
dangerous and a lot of guns and this
team of uh you know assassins or
whatever FBI or C CIA stuff whatever but
something like even doing something like
that could you see the talent he had in
just the small time that you had working
with him yeah so he played a character
who on paper my character was supposed
to be you know his his character pays me
to protect him and my character doesn't
like this guy he doesn't like what he
stands for and moment to moment on set I
saw the Brilliance of Brendan where I
was
fighting not liking
him like I'm not supposed to like this
guy but his Ang on the character was so
just like it was annoying to be H it was
annoying so I'm like I'm not supposed to
like you and so what happened is it bled
into
the the connection between the
characters which I think became sort of
like a not butch Cassy Sundance but it
was like a you could see my character
being ground down by this guy's agenda
and I think him and I just we we didn't
like hang out after said or do any of
that but onset he has this thing of
bringing you in and he's so engaged and
he's so so such a beautiful person I
think that's literally how and when I've
seen him a few times since like at at
cons and stuff he's just beautiful he's
just
so wonderful lastly I know you wanted to
ask me something so and we'll finish you
with this I it's just a fan question on
my go ahead so my fan fan question is as
a patron member um recently I know you
had keano on and I have a story about
Keo where when when I was when I had
production company with Warner Brothers
we sold a we sold a television show and
I was in New York kind of celebrating
that and my agent uh who I was meeting
for dinner called me and he goes you
know where do you want to go to dinner
we got to celebrate everything's on me
and I was like oh great so I picked this
great spot and he goes I'm want to bring
my friend keano and I was like okay cool
did I you know I didn't catch I'm like
okay you cool you're going to bring
somebody so we get there we sit down
we're having fun and uh 20 minutes later
Keo ree sits down you know my agent's
like hey sit down and then my agent
tells him why we're celebrating and he
the way he looked at me and engaged at
me and he
said what you just did
was so difficult to do I'm you know he
didn't say I'm proud of you but he just
like was like I was like oh my God he
was genuinely happy for you and really
cool about like your success and it
wasn't it was just a beautiful person
saying something beautiful and I was
like no one around me has said this
except him everybody else you know what
I mean yeah he's the only person who
actually said it and we had a great
night he ordered some of the best one
I've ever seen in my life yeah and I
just became a fan of him as a person and
I've never seen him since but I know you
recently just inter interviewed him so
as a fan was to be like how do what was
your experience with him because I know
he's a gracious wonderful person and I
watch everything he does I'll just say
that being being with him he he has this
thing well he came on with his band his
two uh band members Brett and Rob and
they were the nicest guys ever and you
know I was told ahead of time like from
one of his friends like hey don't make
it about kanano cuz it's you know it's
kind of the band and they're on tour and
and uh and I dogar right star and and
they've got a great band and I had
worked with Cano in Sweet November I was
a transves that lived next door to
Charlie's throne and and I loved working
with him and I was nervous about having
Koo on because I was like my friend's
like hey have him on and if he has a
good time then it'll be easier to get
him on the podcast alone and so yeah you
know he sits down he comes he comes in
he goes and I go hey can I get you a cup
of coffee he goes uh that that would be
great yeah and I go can you drink out of
my sunspin it's my band he goes oh I
want to hear something and I played a
sunspin song remember that and I was
like cool and Ry and I were so Ryan and
I were so nervous because we we had an
extra camera and we had to make sure
everything was on and recording and I
was like I don't want anything to go
[__] wrong and we're both nervous
right and he sits down I go would you
mind sitting there he goes no it's great
and he sits there and he looks up while
we're recording the first thing he says
I thought I'm going to have to dig stuff
you know he goes I that movie it's
Dracula and I go oh my God I forgot that
you're in that movie and he goes yeah he
goes you got Gary Oldman to sign that
and I'm like yeah and he goes you know I
I once
gave Francis Ford Copa
mushrooms because he directed Dracula
and that was the first thing he said in
the interview and it just made every I
think whether he knew it or not it just
put me at ease and you know when I asked
him questions about how he deals with
life and things like that
he was very you know he's very quirky
he's just he's an odd guy in a in a cool
way but he's very res like he knows but
I think he's he knows a lot more than
you think he's shy and he's well
articulate but I will say this he said
he's comfortable with himself I go what
do you do when you're trying to work
something out or your stress and he goes
Michael um goes I like to be quiet I
like to sit there and close my eyes and
just think about everything and just try
to think it through
and the way he said it and you'll hear
it it's just a couple of things he said
and what you know again I was talking to
three guys a lot but and and after the
show I could tell he enjoyed it and we
went outside and we hung out for like a
half an hour in front of the house
talked about his motorcycle talked about
me working with him talked about our
mutual friends and I just felt like for
someone that's such a big star that
everybody wants a piece of him he
couldn't have been nicer when I said can
we get a picture he yeah yeah and I go
can Ryan get a picture with you he's
yeah he was just he was just like a
genuinely sweet man that's what I'll say
about him so it also sounds like he's
there with
you you know what I mean he's like
sharing the moment with you and I think
that's a that's a he just wants to hang
out he doesn't want to talk about
himself he just wants to talk about
things that people talk about a lot of
times it's like when you're with someone
that you're like enamored by you're like
oh what do we talk about you know just
talk about what you would talk about so
was like oh man I love music what kind
of guitar you have but just
talk and that's the best way to do it
and he's and he's and he's interested
he's interested in in things this is was
this better than you thought you know I
you know I didn't want to do this but I
did it for you I mean that's my own ego
whatever but um I knew that we had fun
talking I don't even remember what we
just talked about but Tom thanks for
being on man I love you I'm sure I'll be
talking to you within an hour so good
good luck to you there you want to say
goodbye to
Ryan Ryan thank you for being here thank
you for allowing how how did you feel
about the interview Ryan I felt great
about it I always like hearing from you
and also this is like a nice different
context and we don't have to talk about
Smallville today yeah we didn't really
talk about small usually we're talking
about something else yeah no but you
opened up about some things and I think
people are going to really um really dig
that and it was a fun conversation so I
love you buddy give Jess a tongue kiss
for me and tell her tell her I'm more
magnetic
never I'll see you later
buddy well there you have it uh 300th
episode uh Tom Welling thank you for
being here it was an absolute delight
and we're just going to jump right into
it um it's been a treat 300 episodes
there's not much else I could say um
Ryan I hope you've had a decent time you
know it's not like we spend 40 hours a
week together we might spend like two or
three hours a week together but uh
ultimately has it been a decent
experience it sure has well I I like
that I like uh you're appreciated I hope
you know that thank you I appreciate you
well dual dual duel double double
appreciation double penetration double
appren double
apprenti Jes uh okay right now uh
without further Ado we're going to do
the uh top tiers this is these are the
top tier patrons who give back to the
show even if it's a small amount or well
the top tiers it's they they really get
back which makes the show possible to be
honest with you and I'm going to read
off their names now we love you go to
patreon.com inside of you and become a
patron to day I'll send you a message
there's you get a lot of good stuff with
it um look at the perks when you go to
the patron page why don't you started
out me me
mey like zo school all right Nancy D
Leah and Kristen little Lisa Yukiko Jill
e Brian h niik p Robert B Jason w Sophie
M Raj C Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Mike E Lon Supremo 99 Mo
Santiago M lean P Matty s blinda n Dave
Hall yeah Dave Hall I love Dave Hall
Dave's a really good guy I really like
hearing his voice I wish I had his
accent this is I'm not doing a good job
of his voice right now Sheila G brand d
Ray H tath the T Tom and Talia M Betsy D
Ranna C Cory k Nexon Michelle a Jeremy C
Brandy D Eugene and Leah Corey Mel s
Christine s Eric H Shane R Andrew M
Oracle Oracle Oracle Amanda R Kevin e
Stephanie K jorel jam and J lean J Luna
R Mike F Stone H Brian L Jules M Kendall
L Jessica B Marisol P Kaylee J Brian a
Maran Louise L Romeo the band Frank B J
T Nikki L April RM Randy ask JD W oral P
Rachel D Melissa H Nick W Stephanie and
Evan Charlene a Don G hello d d Jenny B
John Jennifer R Tina e NG Tracy juny and
Tasha s thanks guys all my
love I'm glad I read all the names D it
made me think of Shrek d d oh my gosh
uh guys I love you thank you for all the
support 300 episodes hopefully uh let's
just take it 50 at a time now let's just
you know know but I I'll do this as long
as you guys are supporting me and um as
long as I have your support I'm here so
thanks and spread the word and let's
make the show bigger and better if we
can so and thanks Bryce and Jason oh
yeah without a doubt I mean without
those guys I mean Bryce is the backbone
of it all and Jason he puts it together
to makes you got you know you know so
people are listening and it's easy to
listen to and it's it's tight and
Jason's editing on the video it's just
he takes care of me takes care of the
guest he takes care of the he puts his
he puts his all into it as does Bryce so
I'm I'm blessed to have all you guys on
the team Ryan Bryce Jason and I'm
blessed to have all you listeners out
there who support the podcast and are
listening and thank you so here's the
here's the 300 more let's just say it
and thanks to Westwood one for all their
support and getting us um advertisers
and uh working so diligently and um
believing in the podcast so thank you
and from the Hollywood Hills in
Hollywood California I am Michael
rosenbom I am Ryan Tails I'm here too
little wave to the camera we love you
guys thanks and uh be good to yourselves
be good to yourselves or
[Music]
self